the Cleveland Browns have a new head
coach Kevin Stefanski the former Vikings
offensive coordinator and he was with
the Vikings organization from 2006 he
arrived with Brad Childress for crying
out loud and now after all those years
in Minnesota Stefanski moves on to
become the head coach of the Cleveland
Browns
it really is kind of strange to think
that he got rewarded for what a bad job
we saw on Saturday and the fact that the
Vikings lost opened the door for him to
be hired on Sunday Chris I got the
impression they were hiring somebody on
Sunday and that if the Vikings somehow
had one they were hiring somebody else
it just shows you how weird and
arbitrary this process can be and how
considerations other than getting the
absolute best guy can overcome you know
just common sense and and this idea that
we have to have somebody now we have to
have somebody now we can't wait a week
we can't wait two weeks even though
that's our guy
so if we can't get that guy we're gonna
get somebody else and I saw a suggestion
last night from someone I think was Mary
Kay Cabot at the glueten Plain Dealer it
was either gonna be Roberts all of the
49ers defensive coordinator or Kevin
Stefanski it all just depended on who
lost the game on Saturday well yeah
that's just absolutely ridiculous I just
don't know anything was say it and I
listened I am you know I just I don't
know what to say
Cleveland's a dumpster fire that's all I
can really say there's a dumpster fire
what what in the world and listen I want
to make sure this we're talking football
here okay this is football this is
nothing personal all right Kevin
Stefanski I've never really met him in
my life I don't know him I'm sure he's a
really fine guy I know some of the human
beings in Cleveland they're good human
being Stefanski good human beings I'm
talking strictly football here I don't
know what the hell you would hire sceva
Stefanski for I'm sorry I don't know
and Mike Zimmer Mike Zimmer is telling
you not to hire him I mean have you
listened to the quotes he says the last
eight weeks of the year he's telling you
Kubiak the greatest thing that's
happened to this since he's been there
everything he praises is Gary Kubiak but
Stefanski is gonna get a head coaching
job what the hell is Cleveland doing all
right I don't know so I just don't get
it
he's not we've watched the offense
there's issues in Minnesota if they
can't run the ball I mean it's the most
basic bullcrap offense we've seen so
what are you really getting here and to
me that's where Cleveland's a dumpster
stuff dumpster fire and Mike the other
thing that bothers me too is the more
and more I hear you know hey Cleveland
the analytics teams running the
organization
Jimmy Haslam's just listens to the
analytics team they're running the squad
hey we were we were doing baseball you
know a few years ago but now we're gonna
tell an NFL team hadn't run the team I
don't get it so back to Cleveland I
don't believe Lynn you're back to the
mistake by the lake I don't know what
the hell's going on there sorry I had to
get it off my chest
no no that's fine I'm glad you said it
not me for a change let me add to a
little bit Paul DePodesta the chief
strategy officer who's a part-time
employee doesn't even live in Cleveland
I was told late in the AA in the regular
season there was a chance he was gonna
leapfrog John Dorsey in the organization
but he wouldn't move to Cleveland but
the guys still got tremendous influence
and they let him hire his guy Stefanski
is the guy he wanted last year must be
right Dorsey wanted Freddie kitchens so
now deep Podesta gets his guy and
there's some reporting out there from
the Canton repository that suggests that
the head coach had to agree to a lot of
things like submitting the game plan in
advance and meeting with the analytics
team having the analytics team pour over
everything just a lot of demands that
make you wonder are you really in charge
and that may be one of the reasons why
josh mcdaniels who we got who would want
to deal with it why would a mr. Vance
key me I mean yes he's just so desperate
you know this is a day basically took a
guy that was like this guy will do
anything to be a head coach oh well
we'll hire you you'll listen to us
submit a game plan to the analytics
department are you freaking kidding me
the analytics department making in-game
decisions about what to do in certain
situations like I'd get the hell out of
here Cleveland that's all I got to say
to you get the hell out of here with
that crap I mean that's unbelievable
that's so dysfunctional I don't know and
again these are fine human beings this
is not personal this is just me Chris
Simms talking football and what I know
and people I know and how organized
nations are run and this just ain't how
it's run I don't know so it just did
bother ease it bothers me and just so
we're clear because the Pro Analytics
crowd can be very loud and very
aggressive right we're not saying
analytics has no place it does but to
give the keys to an analytics guy to
hire his coach and micromanage that
coach like you are a kid playing Madden
right that's what becomes problematic
but you know here's where I see
something that I think is encouraging
for the Browns long term and by long
term and maybe 10-15 years if Paul
DePodesta is going to be hovering around
the organization whispering in the ear
of ownership at some point
let him be accountable let him pick the
coach and let it work or not work
because this time if it doesn't work
it's on him and if this fails then he
needs to go you know to many of these
football organizations have people who
find a way to influence ownership
holiday to get their agenda right yeah
and and when everything goes well they
take the credit and when the stuff hits
the fan they run and hide and say we're
not football people pull them into the
light and make them accountable and if
it works you get the credit and if it
fails you get out of here yeah and and
and I think that and so it's either
gonna so good news Browns pants this is
you're gonna work and great you're gonna
have a team of this contender you
deserve it
Browns fans have suffered for too long
if it doesn't work then maybe Haslem
snaps out of the spell the Paul
DePodesta has on him and says hey Paul
we tried it see you later right you're
out we're gonna try a different way now
where they go from there remains to be
seen but it's it's one way or the other
yeah and I think it brings it all to a
head right we'll see if it works well em
you think it won't well no I don't I
don't you know analytics I'm with you
Mike I mean they're a part of the game
yes to let it overrun your team it just
doesn't tell the truth always you know
it doesn't
hey analytics all the Analects I heard
will Greer was the second best
quarterback in the draft last year yeah
okay right hahaha
Carson Wentz was in the top twenty pick
her top 20 quarterback bullcrap he's not
he's a top six tell me how the analytics
did there there's issues than that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports